(electronic music)
- So my name is Alex O'Keefe.
I am the 2018-19 Kress
Fellow in Art Librarianship.
So I work in the Haas Arts Library,
and I've been working on Ensemble@Yale
for my project as the Kress Fellow.
So the project I'm presenting today
is Enesemble@Yale,
which is a longstanding
project before I got here,
a collaboration between the DHLab
and then the Haas Arts Library,
representative Lindsay King,
in order to preserve Yale's drama history.
What we're doing is we
have digitized programs
from the 1920s through about 2016
that we are asking people to transcribe.
So it's a crowdsource
transcription project,
which is really exciting,
'cause it means we get to
work with people a lot.
And so we basically have
the actors and their roles,
and we're trying to get
people to transcribe the names
so that we have a data
set that we can later use
to maximize asking
questions about the Yale Rep
that we don't know right now.
I think the most exciting
part of this project
has been working to
invigorate a volunteer base.
So when I first came on,
the project was all set up and ready to go
thanks to the DHLab
and all of the efforts
that came before me,
but my big initiative has
been bringing in the people
and getting them excited
about our project.
Since crowdsourcing requires
the people, (laughing)
a crowd, as we say,
the crowd in crowdsourcing,
we have been trying really
hard to create programming
and create opportunities
for people to come together
over these exciting materials
and learn more about the history with us
as we also produce the product
of data set for later use.
So, once we have all of the
crowdsource data together,
we're working now on what
we want that to look like
for the population to
access it, essentially.
So we definitely are
working on adjusting it
into FindIt at Yale, which
is the Yale side of things,
but we also are hoping
to do some more data
visualization options,
like using Gephi and
social networking mapping
in order to show more of the relationships
between these people and their lives,
again, from the 20s through about 2016.
So the conversations we're having today
have been really exciting to be a part of,
especially listening
to all of the speakers
before coming to the poster session.
I'm hoping that I'll trade
off with my colleague soon
to walk around and talk to more people,
but it's just the energy in the room
as well as the diversity of
digital humanities projects
is just so exciting to see,
and to see how everyone is
maximizing their different areas
to create these really
interesting projects.
Collaborating with the
DHLab has been excellent.
Everyone has been really helpful.
We have lots of times we have
to troubleshoot together,
and everyone's very open and helpful
in every angle that
we've had and (inaudible).
So we've been very excited
to represent Beyond Boundaries today.
- My name is Maya Levin.
I'm a junior.
I'm studying the History
of Science and Medicine
and Ecology and Evolutionary Biology,
but I'm here in my capacity
as a History of Science
and Medicine major,
and I'm a third-year undergraduate.
So I'm working with Dr. Carolyn Roberts
in the History of Science
and Medicine department
to look at manifests
from slave trade ships
during the transatlantic slave trade.
Looking at the Latin
pharmaceutical abbreviations
of medication names,
expanding them into usable Latin terms,
and then finding an
English vernacular name
for those medications,
and eventually turning
them into a database
that people can use to answer
historical questions across time
about medications both
explicitly in the slave trade
and more broadly.
I'm also hoping to sort
of trace those medications
back to diseases that people
were expecting to encounter
during the slave trade,
as we can look at, sort of,
likelihood, costs, and
amount of medications
that people were bringing
on to slave trade ships.
Yeah, so lessons learned.
I think that transcription
is something that is
really an important skill
and that we shouldn't lose it
as digitization becomes
something really important.
Because though it may seem
that this is sort of legible
and doable handwriting,
I'm not sure how much the
camera can pick it up,
it's actually not able to be read
by a digital tool at this point.
So it still needs to be done by a human.
And I think that's a skill
that is really important to keep up
as we think about the way
that digitization and
humanities will stay united.
And then another lesson learned, really,
is that looking at historical medication,
it's important to sort of
take a lens of judgment away.
I think it's very easy
to look at these medications and think,
obviously, they shouldn't
be giving anyone mercury.
I don't know what you were doing.
But actually, looking at the ways
that people were developing
medication over time
and thinking critically about that,
but also giving them a
little bit of benefit,
I think can give you insight
into people in this time period
and the way that they were
thinking about medicine.
That's much more valuable.
So next step is really
expansion of the data set.
For now, we have about 75
entries in this format,
but we've only worked with two entries
from actual manifests.
So expanding those,
hoping to find more
manifests in the future,
and then hoping to find other students
that can help expand this data set
so that it can be turned
into an interactive database
that people can really use.
- So one thing, I think,
that appears clearly in
the Beyond Boundaries today
is that the field is, in general,
of digital humanities is evolving.
We are not presenting projects wholly.
We are discussing together
about what makes digital
humanities meaningful.
And that comes to a good time,
because I think the (inaudible)
needs to be reshaped and modified,
because a lot of things were
enough endless and cycling questions,
that are now maybe a bit behind us,
considering how inspiring
and how interesting
the question and the things
that were discussed today were.
So, that's a great, great...
I think there are great
hopes for this field.
- The project was part
of a graduate seminar
focused on 17th-century
French literature (inaudible).
And the project was kind
of a three-week period
within that course in which we took
basically a manuscript
of a 17th-century comedy
and learned to text encode it
using (mumbling) standards
and then realized it
through a number of different interfaces.
So each group decided to envision
the scene that they were
responsible for in a specific way.
But we were also working with a team
at a university in Seattle.
So we were Skyping with them throughout
and collaborating with
them on the project.
- Translating the book
from the object books
to a digital version of everything
is also a way to reread the work,
the literary work, in a new way.
It's not just putting the text online.
It's rethinking about our
relationship to a book,
our relationship to literary works,
and it's a lot of new
questions and new topics
for us, our researcher, as researcher.
- So we were able to communicate directly
with our partners in Washington via Skype,
and so we met in the Beinecke Library
and went back and forth about
the work we did over email.
So that kind of kept the workflow
pretty simple and functional.
- [Interviewer] Would one of you like
to walk us through the project?
- I can do it.
Okay, so, as Doyle said,
we all designed five different interfaces.
And as you can see,
they all look pretty different.
And I think that one thing that we learned
is that your interface really changes
as a function of what you
want to portray in the text,
what's the most important.
So, for example, these top two,
this one is done by myself,
whereas Madison completed this one.
And these ones are, I would say,
much more about the
performativity of the text,
much less about maybe the text itself.
Whereas this one, which is Doyle's,
showcases variations across
different editions of the text,
so it's a much more,
academic, we could say, edition.
Yeah, so we all chose different
scenes, and as Walid said,
we kind of had to read our scenes
to see what was the most important thing
content-wise or more structurally
to share about the work.
- And you had to debate with your partners
at the University of Washington in Seattle
to elaborate those interfaces.
- Yeah.
So this one is animated.
It's designed to function
like a WhatsApp message,
so we made the choice to not
modernize the text at all,
but rather, just to kind of show
how this kind of conversation
is still relevant today.
This specific text, or this scene,
is kind of about gender
roles in the 17th century
as they were conveyed in this play.
So we have color coded the text messages
to show the different genders.
And so we kind of envisioned this more
as like an animated interface
that could be used as a pedagogical tool
to show how one can read
kind of at any level
of French or of expertise
of the 17th century,
how one could read this text today.
- So my scene deals
with a bourgeois woman.
She's pretending to be from a higher class
than she actually is.
And she says all sorts of lies
about the way that she has a carriage,
and as the scene progresses, however,
the other characters see through her lies
and the image that
she's trying to project.
And I was reading a lot about selfies
and, sort of, social
appearances on social media
and thinking through these questions
that were very present in the scene.
We think of them as contemporary.
So I wanted to show that.
It's sort of one of the
subtexts of the scene,
and I wanted to make that
apparent with a visual.
So I chose the mirror,
what would be like an iPhone today,
and showed her self image cracking
as all of her lies are
revealed to be lies,
and was really thinking about how
to make the subject matter more relatable
to a contemporary reader.
- My name is Azza El Siddique,
and I am a second-year MFA graduate
in the sculpture department.
The project title is named Tirhaga,
and it is using neural style transfer
to generate images in the likeness
of an artist that recently passed away.
I've learned a lot.
(laughs)
I personally don't have a background
in coding or programming,
and so, I mean I've taken, like,
online Codecademy classes (laughing).
But the DHLab has helped me so much
in order to kind of, like,
set up the system and
teach me how to use it,
and being able to use it
and just constantly learning
while working with the programs.
Yeah, it's like, constantly new for me.
(laughs)
Yeah.
So, with like the neural style transfer,
there's multiple ways that you can use it.
You can use, like, color scale
in order to shift colors around,
as well as content and style weight.
So I found that to be really generative
in the ways that taking
certain content images
and applying the style and
to play around with that,
to kind of start to understand
the program a bit more
and to understand what it's doing.
Yeah, so, that was...
Yeah, that was like ways
like learning through the program.
So this is a image, like,
of the artist's painting.
So this is one of the paintings,
and this is another painting.
So what I had done is
use these two paintings
as the style weights,
and from there, I had taken
images from his iPhone
that are used as, like,
inspirational references,
and Photoshopped them together
in order to generate a new
image that would be like,
in the likeness of a potential painting
he could've created.
So this is a painting of his,
but also combining multiple paintings
to kind of create different
colorways as well.
Just like, having access to the technology
and also its ability
to process the information a lot quicker.
So being able to have the images available
in a shorter time.
Yeah, and just having the support as well.
Yeah, to like,
learn the program, and, yeah.
It's been a really great experience, yeah.
(laughs)
- My name is Adam Erickson.
I'm an undergraduate student, senior.
I'm majoring in Applied
Mathematics and Physics.
I'm working with a professor
at the school management,
and we are working on
building an interface
to view time series data.
And this time series happens to be
topic modeling on the Wall Street Journal,
so its corpus of natural language.
And it doesn't fit really well
as a visualization on paper,
so to really explore all the features,
thought it'd be good to
build a web interface.
So we used React.js,
which is a JavaScript library,
(mumbling) Facebook open source project
for building user interfaces.
We also used another open source library
from the Department of Energy
for doing time series data,
which wraps React around D3.
Basically, because both React and D3
want to make updates to the DOM,
Document Object Model, of HTML,
and this package helps them
play nicely with each other.
We do this so that then we
can load in the CSV files.
These files are the time series data,
so, you know,
value at certain points in time,
such that we could
someday feed in new data,
and we wouldn't have to
update any of the code.
So we have a menu here
where you can choose
which time series you want
to appear on the plot,
and this, we hope, could
be of arbitrary length
sometime in the future.
And you see, here,
I'll un-click them, some of them.
But you see, it starts with
a totally blank canvas,
which we'll get to in a second here.
And then, as you start to select them,
it begins to draw the plots.
And as you mouse over,
it tells you the value of the time series
at certain points in time.
So because these are newspaper articles,
each topic is a topic that
might appear in the newspaper,
and then the value for a certain month
is the article which most
represents that topic
during that month.
So like the top headline, more or less.
And you can add a bunch and overlay them,
for example, here we have
the topic of police crime,
mobile devices, and internet.
And you can mouse over them
and see how they change
throughout time and compare them.
And then, if you select
them all on one axes,
you can get some more absolute comparisons
of their relative proportions.
So you might see a spike
right here in internet,
and then think, like,
"Oh, what kind of was
happening around that time?"
And because all the proportions
over all the topics sum to one,
you might see, like,
oh, when this one went up,
interest in the other one went down.
Things like that.
Yep.
Yeah, so this is still prototype,
but one quick thing you can
do to check out an example
might be, okay,
I'll choose a topic of the internet.
So then you can see the time series
and see, like, oh, in 1985,
there was a lot less
discussion of the internet
in the newspaper than there
was right here, around 2000,
the dot-com bubble.
You can see there's some
articles about DoubleClick.
I was alive at that time,
but not super conscious,
so I don't remember this,
but I know around 2000s,
a lot was happening with the internet.
And the one which really has a huge spike
is if you choose natural disasters,
which you can see even dwarfs
the spike in the internet,
and this is right after Hurricane Katrina
is when the topic proportion
really spikes in the newspaper.
So, yeah, those are the sorts of things,
trends you might like to look for
and use this interface for.
And really, what's nice,
is you could choose an
arbitrary number of topics
and not have to worry about
how it updates the screen.
Definitely, I learned a lot
about front-end development
using JavaScript and React
and things like that.
Asynchronous programming
especially is difficult,
so if you're writing something
more low-level or back-end
or like a project you might do
in one of the CS classes here,
you can kind of anticipate
how it's going to be used.
But when you make a user interface,
you don't know in what order
the user might do things,
so you have to build it such that
clicks, drags, scrolls, whatever
could happen in any order.
So you're prepared for anything
the user might do to use it well,
or even if they were trying to break it
in testing or something.
So that was really difficult,
and then that is what React helps do
for building user interfaces.
It really makes it a lot
easier to handle State
and to write the program, the interface,
such that, oh, it doesn't matter
what order the user does things in,
because it's declarative.
So I want to declare how
the front end will be used.
So yeah, a lot about that,
and that was really interesting.
(electronic music)